are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset
all right this is episode number
155 with dr peter pry if you do not know
who dr peter pry is
let me formally introduce him to you
number one he is the world's leading
expert
on wmd's weapons of mass destruction and
emps which we'll get into emps later on
today we got a lot of questions on the
mps executive director of the task force
on national and homeland security a
congressional advisory board dedicated
to achieving protection of the united
states from electromagnetic pulse emps
cyber attacks mass destruction terrorism
and other threats to critical civilian
infrastructure on an accelerated basis
was former intelligence officer with the
cia responsible for analyzing ready
soviet and russian nuclear strategy
operational plans military doctrine
threats perceptions and developing u.s
period for strategic warning that's from
85 to 96
has written multiple books his latest
book blackout warfare attacking the us
electric power grid a revolution in
military affairs just came out last year
bbc took one of his books
uh soviet war scare in turn into a
documentary national geographic took
another one of his book electric
armageddon and it became a tv
documentary and he holds a certification
in nuclear weapons design that is our
guest today dr peter pry thank you so
much for making the time for being on
the podcast well thank you so much for
having me yes it's it's a uh you know
folks this is going to be a very much of
us this is such a serious podcast today
that
i think i have to manage expectations
with you up front
my colleague here adam never wears
glasses yeah the topic is so serious
that he had to put on glasses today
because he had to at least look like he
knows what he's talking about in this
topic so that was his positioning you
took but you gotta fake it till you make
it okay yeah
if you want to compete throw your
glasses on
but look there's there's a lot of stuff
going on today here's here's some i mean
i got a lot of questions i just kept
writing questions down
uh uh why is russia acting weak with
ukraine misconceptions about nuclear
wars and emps the mindset of a russian
how different it is than an american the
eastern versus the western who's more
paranoid and prepared is it us is it
russia is it china why are we willing to
entertain a war with russia over ukraine
can an old nuclear weapon break down a
lot of our nuclear weapons are 30 plus
years old can that break down is it like
a car is it something that can work even
10 20 30 years from now or do we have to
update them
super emp weapons what's the best
defense against nuclear weapons and emps
anyways there's a lot of different
things i want to cover with you here
today on the podcast but i'll just open
it up to you i gave the intro if you
don't mind sharing with the audience a
little bit more about your background so
they will know what things you've worked
on and it will get into specific topics
sure i was the uh
chief of staff of the congressional emp
commission for
for 17 years
uh and the uh that commission was
headed by the the world's actual
foremost expert on electromagnetic pulse
dr william graham my privilege to uh
work for him as the chief of staff he
was president reagan science advisor
uh he ran nasa uh he's the free world's
albert einstein of emp and when i was in
elementary school he was a young defense
scientist who was on the defense science
team that discovered the emp phenomena
during the 1962 starfish prime high
altitude nuclear test
you know i worked on the house armed
services committee professional staff
with a very wide portfolio
nuclear weapons electromagnetic pulse
but also nato enlargement i ended up
going to
most of the countries and that were
former warsaw countries that wanted to
come into nato
and i advised congress against expanding
nato eastward precisely because i
thought it would result in a new cold
war with russia that we didn't want
and uh and that we would be unable to
defend these countries because we can't
project power that far
and uh it's right in russia's backyard
and they can project the power more uh
moreover it would provoke russia lead
them to be uh to to rely even more
heavily on nuclear weapons to deal with
the emerging threat of a of an ex an
eastward expanding nato
um
you mentioned my cia background uh so
that uh i worked also
before i uh joined the cia i was uh an
analyst in the in the uh what used to be
called it doesn't exist anymore but it
was called the us arms control and
disarmament agency
and so i had a i was a verification
analyst
uh responsible for you know looking at
are the soviets complying with the arms
control treaties and um and that gave me
great insight into
how the arms control system works you
know and uh they weren't fi they were
violating all the treaties practically
uh but within the arms control
association it gave me insight you know
uh the state department uh and uh people
in the west were very very reluctant to
ever admit that any treaty was being
violated so in order to
in order to
[Music]
acquire enough data you know to say
uh that yeah the soviets are violating
the treaty
it would often take years and years and
there'd be a non-compliance before we
would withdraw from the treaty
but uh you know that my background as my
professional background has been uh in
uh
you know nuclear weapons and strategy or
national security issues all my life
uh i guess i should mention my
uh it goes even back before i was born
you know you mentioned you were a
refugee from iran my own parents were
refugee grandparents were refugees from
communism
uh you know they fought on the side of
the whites and lost to the reds during
the revolution and they came over here
in the 1920s and there had been a strong
vein of anti-communism i was raised with
that
my both my uh my my family my father my
uncles fought in world war ii
and we were always
more or less lectured that you can lose
freedom in a single generation and that
someday the bad guys
the fascists or the communists are going
to come for us so we need to be prepared
we need to be strong and we need to
defend this country and that was trimmed
into my head when i was a kid and i was
studying military history
you know when i was a teenager you know
my first first book
uh
i think that that set me on the path i
read when i was 13 years old was herman
khan's on thermal nuclear war and i said
that's what i want to do 13 years old
yeah yeah because that those are i
learned from military history that
the military technologies that are most
decisive in every every period whether
it was alexander the great cyrissa which
is a longer spear than anybody else had
during those classical periods or
whether it was the
uh you know the organization of the
roman legions you know that used
catapults and uh had better
organizations than other armies the
technology tends to be decisive in
future wars and nuclear weapons were the
decisive weapon of our era
and still are
and so i thought well if i can be
becoming expert in this and help
protect freedom protect the free world
protect the united states by making my
contribution that way
that's what i'm going to do
and i
i tried to join
i try to
follow in the footprint friends of my my
uh my father
and wanted to join
go to the vietnam war
you know but i was rejected you know
because my eyesight back then was so bad
i've had lasik since but i was uh
legally blind you know at the time and
nobody would take me and so i said well
maybe i can get into the cia and
and the rest is
the story of the rest of my professional
life
flows from that what a career thank you
for your service we also learned that
the cia is not too concerned about
eyesight i didn't know that before but
that was good to learn about that but
but going going through this so
you you said a lot of different things
so this is this has been this has been
ingrained it's in your dna you've been
wired you
felt the fear and the anxiety angst uh
communism creates control creates losing
your freedom creates do you think
america
is as paranoid today you know how they
say only the paranoid survive do you
think america is as paranoid today
as they used to be uh years ago where
they treated enemies in a different way
are we a little bit more cocky loose
uh you know arrogant and
you know a little bit too much of let's
share all our secrets with the world and
everything we're doing and you think you
think we're still in that paranoid mind
where we're worried about the enemy like
before are we a little bit more looser
today
i don't think the united states has ever
been paranoid uh i think the a great
and that that frankly uh is perhaps one
of the things that threatens our our
very existence
uh i and i think the thing that makes
the world so dangerous is
between the free world and the
totalitarian
dictatorships that we face today
there's a broad gulf
not just in terms of freedom but in
terms of strategic culture
countries like russia north korea
iran
you know china
are
they're strategic cultures that are
are paranoid
genuinely paranoid uh so that they see
threats that don't even exist
and so they're willing to overreact and
over prepare
and uh and strike out
uh against threats that are fantasies
in their minds we're just the opposite
our civilization is what i would call
dysfunctionally optimistic
you know we think that everybody loves
us or we want the rest of the world to
love us we think that the rest of the
world understands that we're not the
aggressors we don't do pearl harbors
uh you know we this this flows from the
nature of the civilizations i should
provide some clarification why is it
that these totalitarian states and
military dictatorships think this way
and have these perceptions that's
because
you know internally
you know the
political power comes out of the barrel
of a gun for them most of their leaders
have murdered their way to the top they
have constitutions and laws that are
fake
you know that are just intended to
uh increase the totalitarian power of
the state over their people
it's
they don't
the way they operate internally is not
through negotiation and compromise and
contracts and the rule of law they
operate
the way
criminal gangs operate and uh in the end
you know it's the survival of the
fittest it's might makes right uh
there's the
it's a zero-sum game it's not a win-win
kind of an outcome uh there's the living
and the dead
and that's how it operates within places
like russia china north korea and iran
and so they project their
experience and the domestic hells that
they've created onto the world stage and
they figure everybody else is like that
so they um you know and that's how the
world operates for us it's just the
opposite our domestic society
believes in win-win outcomes we try to
negotiate differences
we try to we have contracts in the rule
of law we believe in fair play
uh
and uh
and we think though and we think the
rest of the world is like that or
and this is manifest for example and the
numerous arms control treaties that
we've signed with the soviet union and
now russia over the years
and we never seem to learn you know they
violate ev all every one of them and uh
and and we never seem to learn that for
them these contracts are not binding you
know uh you know that they're willing to
cheat on them uh
because they don't believe in something
we have i guess a manifestation of this
thing is is in our view in our in our
culture on our civilizational culture we
believe in this thing called peace for
example there's a condition of peace and
then there's war worse for these other
civilizations
there is only in war you know there's
war within the society to stay in power
uh you're constantly at war with the
other side even though even though we
call it peace
it's really from their perspective
the early moves in the chess game you're
moving the pawns during the period of
peace but you're really at war and
you're getting ready for the war that's
going to come
and uh
this makes us extremely vulnerable that
is why we are constantly taken by
surprise in the wars that we end up get
engaging in because we fail to
understand that other civilization one
of my jobs at the
cia when i worked there was to
understand the threat perceptions
of the other side what is their military
doctrine how do they think we could get
into a nuclear war how did they think
p that's not an easy thing to do it's
one of the hardest things to do to stand
outside of your civilization try to put
yourself in the mind
of your adversary and we don't do that
well uh uh you know uh uh and
so you've got
uh the worst possible combination here
when it comes to the
clash of civilizations you know a
totalitarian civilization that's
extremely paranoid sees threats
everywhere is ready to strike out
and extremely
naive dysfunctionally optimistic
thinking
that we can solve any problem that
nobody sees us as a threat and that
actions that we take will not be
perceived as existential threats to our
adversaries that they understand we're
not going to attack them
it's the deadliest combination you can
have
for getting into a world war you know
you said a lot there and i want to
unpack a lot of things you talk about to
me
that's the mindset in the world of
business it's the different mindset
between a founder
who builds a business versus an
executive that comes in for a job the
founder is always wartime and sometimes
it becomes problematic when it's not
wartime it's peace time but you're
always paranoid the executive's like oh
we got plenty of money in the bank we
can spend the money you know sometimes
in america
presidents come up thinking we have so
much money in the back we can spend it
it's not a big deal we're already
powerful we can do this so they're not
as paranoid as they once used to be my
father says never is a very powerful
powerful word word
you said we've never been paranoid are
you saying never as in 1776 or never as
in 40 years 60 years 80 years 100 years
well i'm speaking relative terms
compared to the north koreans and the
chinese and the russians and our
contemporary adversaries i don't think
we've ever
been as paranoid as they uh
and uh including founding fathers oh
including founding fathers if we
understand maybe we're using the word
paranoid in different ways i mean a
paranoid paranoia is a dysfunctional
psychological condition
that means that you live in a fantasy
world where you imagine that you are
surrounded by threats some of them may
be real but many of them are not and uh
i think uh uh
uh i don't think that describes america
in any phase of its history if anything
we have been a nation of optimists uh
throughout
uh the founding fathers take them as an
example you know
uh you know uh they had i would describe
them as very optimistic people because
they believed
uh
you know they believed that uh god
intended men to be free
uh which i think is true
uh you know they believed in the ability
of human beings to
use rational rationalism to govern
themselves which is why we had the
american revolution
uh you know the amer the whole reason
for the american revolution
it was a a a a a gamble on human
optimism you know on on on the ability
of human beings to be free
that you didn't need to have a monarchy
basically a tyranny and in order to have
a good society in order to keep order in
society that people were capable
you know
in a very decentralized way because the
founders vision of
of what america should be
is very different from what it is today
but they had had this vision of a
federalism with a small f where
people would be governing themselves in
their hamlets in their villages and
that's where most governance would take
place and then at the level of the
states okay that would be the next level
and the least amount of power was
supposed to be in the federal government
in washington this is a revolution in
the way men were supposed to be governed
you know not a top-down system where a
king is deciding everything for you and
it's implemented on ministers and your
peasants are just supposed to obey you
know what an optimistic vision of human
nature and of uh and of how to build a
good society and uh throughout our our
our history we have uh we have believed
in that look at our trust in bringing
immigrants into this country you know
even though uh uh you know there were
lots of prejudices and biases we had
this faith in in the ability of human
beings to use rationalism and to enjoy
freedom so that we would bring in
catholics uh immigrants of of different
races uh and and that we could put them
all together in this mix uh you know and
it would all work in america it would
make america
not only would make it a better place
and an even freer and more prosperous
place and they were and they were right
you know uh they were right for anyway
for a long time uh you know the system
seems to be breaking down today but
that's not because the founders were
wrong about the fundamentals is because
we have forgotten the fundamentals
question about the
pat brought up the topic of only the
paranoid survive and
essentially the debate that you guys are
having right now is the optimism versus
paranoia how much of the paranoia that
the north koreans the russians the
iranians chinese have
stems from
borders versus
the united states i mean we're very
lucky i mean our founding fathers and
our fathers before them had to sail
across the mayflower and you know the
whole story just to get to a place where
they could have their religious freedoms
and and free from persecution and they
found this essentially
utopian society where basically you
didn't have to worry about getting
attacked on mass scale i mean i get it
native americans and we can kind of have
all that but
when you're looking at china or russia's
borders they border china russia the
east end
borders iran china north korea i mean we
don't have to bust out a map right now
but how much of that paranoia is just
naturally built in that you mentioned
versus the utopian
optimism that stems here in america it
just comes from our simple borders no i
i think you're absolutely right i mean
another another way of putting it is
their histories the different histories
that we have you know as you point out
uh ours is a an incredibly benign and
relatively bloodless history i mean the
only major war we've we fought on this
soil was the american civil war you know
750 000 dead and that was more than a
century ago okay uh
all that time since the our wars have
been fought over
overseas and even in the great wars
world war one and world war ii our
casualties compared to the casualties
that everybody else suffered were
relatively light you know uh you know
three hundred thousand uh dead in world
war ii versus uh you take
the soviet union lost 30 million dead in
the very place where the ukraine war is
happening now they're called the
bloodlands for that reason 30 million
dead
and uh
china you know lost tens of millions in
in in the world war ii uh you know cari
the koreas lost millions of people and
and this is in the 20th century it's not
uh it's not a long time ago right you
know they're losing tens of thousands of
people now and if you look back across
the history of those areas you know
where these stay where these states are
they are red with blood and there are
constant wars uh
just a few we take russia you know
beginning uh you know in the in the
medieval period the invasions by the
mongols invaded by the swedish empire
invaded by napoleon you know world war
one and then of course uh uh the nazis
in world war ii invaded again
and uh
uh an extremely bloody history and for
the for the for them uh you know what i
uh
their their uh uh you know their
paranoia is understandable because of
their history it flows from their
history um
we shouldn't think of them as irrational
but they're differently rational because
of their history
and that rationality is so different
from ours because their historical
experience is so different from ours
that it isn't it we
that they don't think like us and and
and it is not easy to anticipate you
know and have a meeting of minds and all
the rest i think that that's where the
highlight yeah is that we think a little
bit differently because very differently
they're naturally paranoid whereas we're
naturally optimistic
let me ask you guys this question let me
ask you let me ask both of you guys this
question
is uh
who do they not trust
more the people right do the russians
trust their government more than they
trust america
does america trust our government more
than we trust uh uh you know the enemy
the people
where i'm going with this is like you
said when america was first found that
it was about the federalism with the
lower case f well you said a small f
right okay which means we made the
decisions for our lives and to each a
zone go find a way to make money we're
not going to get in your way we didn't
really have that much taxes back then it
was you know survival of the fittest go
be industrious create an economy create
a small business build something for
your family here's some land xyz today
the government is massive
so today
you know i can speak for myself and some
of the friends that i speak to it seems
like some people are more paranoid
and who they don't trust sometimes today
is the us government with their
decision-making process so there's an
element of paranoia today because
america is not what america was founded
on it's a different america today than
what it was before and this is left and
right
they both like a big government they
both like control they both want feel
they can make the right decision for us
where based on what you're saying the
founding fathers more
hey i think you can reason and your
ability to reason we trust you go figure
out a way to win for your family and
we're going to leave it up to you so
paranoia to me is also different for
different positions like as a general
the military i would hope our general is
somewhat paranoid for the frontline guys
i would hope they're a little bit
paranoid for folks who are working in
your world i hope you go to sleep at
night trying to think what putin's next
15 moves are
because if you're not i'm deeply
concerned so
the part i think about paranoid is more
proper preparation you know prevents
poor performance right we're overly
prepared against the enemy do you think
the concept of paranoia has changed
today with the people of america towards
the government versus the enemy or do
you think
yeah we should still go back to being
more optimistic because future does look
bright everything's gonna eventually
work itself out
okay
maybe we should use the word suspicious
you know for for some of these things uh
this idea of uh
of uh paranoia or suspicion of the of of
the government uh i i think the uh
i think
part of the problem in our society is
that we're less suspicious or less
paranoid many of us than we should be
uh you know
one of the principles of
of the founders one of the consensus
views that existed and this is right in
the
you know in the federalist papers and
on all the rest is is is the american
people are expected to be suspicious of
government that was part and that was
one of the things that made the american
character different
we believed in
rugged individualism and
self-sufficiency
we were supposed to be a nation of of
farmers and small shopkeepers
they understood the principle
as thomas jefferson said that government
governs best which governs the least
okay the behind that principle is the
understanding that the increase of
government power inevitably erodes your
freedom you cannot have stronger and
stronger government and be free you know
because you're giving government more
and more control over your powerful and
therefore
the founders expected americans to be
extremely suspicious of government and
indeed in the fount in those days before
television and radio
one of the entertainments people had was
politics people would get together in
bars and taverns they would listen to
political speeches for hours they were
much more engaged i think than americans
are today we we think of ourselves as
more informed and more sophisticated
they were very
sophisticated and well-read
those early americans and uh
and uh
and that's one of the reasons why they
you know the they they
they were suspicious of the growth of
government at any level you know whether
it was at the uh the village level or
the state level or and especially at the
federal level and indeed the the
federalist papers
uh famous papers written by madison and
monroe
uh you know and ham and alexander
hamilton
were written to try to convince
in the aftermath of the american
revolution you know where we had just
thrown off a monarch
they were written to try to convince the
states you need to come together you
know in a federal government
and will have a centralized government
in washington to manage relations
between the states and to defend the
country and to manage foreign policy but
don't worry this government in
washington isn't going to become another
tyranny because the states didn't
believe that there were a lot of people
called the anti-federalists who didn't
want that they said we just fought in a
revolution to get out from under
monarchy so the whole debate over the
constitution and the federalist papers
showed how suspicious people were of the
growth of government and uh and uh
and and that
basically
that that limited government you know
produced the america that we enjoy today
up until i guess until the progressive
era started changing things you
mentioned about taxes for example low
taxes you know people didn't
have to pay income taxes it was
unconstitutional to pay income taxes
until the progressives changed that i
think in 1910 or 1930
and they amended yeah they amended the
constitution and that opened the
floodgates because one of the things the
founders you know the reason it was
unconstitutional is they they understood
that if you gave government access to
people's income and you could tax them
uh i think the phrase was government
will eat out the substance of the people
and basically that's that's that was
what has happened and led to the
the explosive growth of government uh
today people unfortunately i think are
much more trusting of government than
they were
throughout most of this country's
history now there are exceptions of
course people who uh who are
conservatives uh who you know understand
the history of this country and the
principles on which it's founded uh tend
to be you know suspicious of government
and increasingly so because of the
greatly expanded power of government but
there is also
half of america's family i mean the you
know the democrat party uh you know
people who actually want to believe have
socialism you know uh really communism
is what it is they call it socialism and
democratic socialism to dress it up but
it it really comes down to to uh
full-blown communism in terms of what
the way they're behaving and and and
what they're after and these people
actually think government is the answer
to all problems
and
they uh
they they want the government to take
care of them they want the government to
save them from climate change from uh
institutional racism uh from all of
these fantasy threats
that the government tells them are real
uh and uh is the reason we should give
more power to government to save them
and protect them and uh and to protect
them also from people who disagree with
them you know because uh if you disagree
with them uh the idea of being able to
have a civilized debate and argument uh
the con
rationalism requires you to respect
other people's point of view and concede
that they may be sincere and not evil
and uh and that you need to have a
conversation with them and convince them
to your point of view that is being
rapidly lost in our society by the by
the other side which has all the
earmarks of becoming a
an effect in a totalitarian movement
within our country and threatens uh
and not just threatens but frankly i
think we've already lost we're i don't
think we're a constitutional republic
today i think we're we're we're uh we're
a soft we're in the faces of soft
tyranny and and why do i say that you
know because uh i think for some years
we've uh we we haven't been a
constitutional republic the first year
of the trump administration uh not
president trump's fault but the democrat
party's fault when they brought the
the uh
the false charges uh and and tried to
impeach the president you know for being
a uh
you know for being a manchurian
candidate all of which has been proven
to be false that he was an agent of
russia and repeatedly abused the
intelligence agencies to try to
basically have a coup d'etat against a
legitimately elected american president
the point is that both political parties
they have a true constitutional republic
have got to respect the constitution and
and the rule of law and recognize the
legitimacy of the political power of the
other side when they win elections
fairly okay and that didn't happen
right from the beginning of the trump
administration so you don't really have
we haven't really lived in a true
constitutional republic what we've been
undergoing is a civil war you know
between
a nascent totalitarian movement on one
side
and the people who still believe in the
constitution on the other side
and uh
and we're trying to i hope that that we
can get back to becoming a
constitutional republic again but there
are you know very profound
[Music]
problems in our strategic in our
civilizational culture and our politics
and and all the rest that have have
resulted in this and it's not going to
be easy to overcome uh we may go the way
of most uh free systems i mean history
is is not populated mostly by free
systems mostly they are tyrannies and
military dictatorships and authoritarian
type systems because freedom is hard
it's hard to be a free people you know
you have to be actively engaged you have
to be
you have to be the kind of american the
founders had in mind you know someone
who was going to be always suspicious of
government always jealous of his of his
ability to manage himself it was a point
of pride among americans for example
you know throughout most of our history
not to take charity the idea of taking a
handout from your neighbor would be
disgraceful you know it was considered
a sign of manhood uh and uh and uh uh
and and uh and of good citizenship that
you should be able to take care of
yourself and your own family you know
and if you couldn't uh that was that was
a source of shame and and and that has
that very healthy instinct you know has
gone away
to an attitude that people feel the
government owes them a living you know
uh
uh but these are we that that's a topic
we could go on on an all afternoon but
yeah i think we're in great trouble uh
that way oh on the other side
where the russians are concerned for
example if we're talking about that i
mean
putin is more popular
right now i mean he's probably
more popular than he's ever been uh you
know despite the ukraine amongst his own
people yeah among his own can we stay on
this topic i have one other question
before we go into putin i want to get
your respect on what's going on in putin
versus what we see on media so
just just a curiosity
if america is building the country that
it's building the founding fathers and
they're going through what they're going
through
you know i applied for a job when i was
21 years old when i got out of the
military and i'm dating a girl who's
working on morgan stanley dean witter i
know nothing about securities stocks
bonds mutual funds nothing i'm a 1.8 gpa
kid i'm a hummer mechanic this girl's
like hey listen you gotta get into
financial services i send my resume to
everybody i have no clue who goldman
sachs is at the time i send my resume do
you realize i wanted to see the reaction
of the people who saw my resume my
resume showed haagen-dazs
bob's big boy burger king military and
ballet total fitness i wish i would pay
money to see the reaction of the hiring
manager that says
what the hell is this guy thinking about
sending a degree
you know a resume like this to us but i
was oblivious goldman would never hire
somebody like me my pedigree my
background who i was so goldman had high
standards
don't you think a country who offers as
much as we do
our filtering system of who
we we must keep a higher standard to
you know what people have to do to earn
certain things versus trying to please
everybody yeah i don't know if i can
explain this properly look i'm a
byproduct of immigration that ended up
being here and when we came here we
didn't have a lot to offer i'm thankful
for it i'm not coming from that point of
view all i'm saying is
if if we are from the mindset of
here's everything america offers what
are you bringing to the table okay so
for me i'm like i'm gonna pay my debt
off by serving your country okay and i'm
gonna pay my debt off to you for america
giving me the opportunity
by
paying a lot of taxes creating jobs and
not having to rely on the government so
taxpayers don't have to help my family
out and i'm just going to be a citizen
that gives back to this country
what happened to the what do you bring
to the table
what happened to what do you bring to
america what happened to what do you
offer us
instead of let's just take everybody
it's like tomorrow goldman sachs
announces and says look
we're offering jobs to everybody we
don't care if you got a you know
anything we don't care if you got a
background we don't care if you got
anything if you've never had a job
before we're hiring that would be
ludicrous for goldman sachs to announce
something like that if america was
supposed to be that country why do we
drop our standards
and turn it instead of
keeping high standards for people we're
almost begging people to say oh it's
okay don't worry about it let us take
care of you oh it's okay not what are
you gonna do for us when did that shift
take place
well uh
i understand i mean this is outside the
immigration policy is not my area of
expertise but i'm familiar with some of
it but it happened in i think in the in
the 60s uh you know when uh
they decided to
uh
uh
broaden
immigration so that would start bringing
in a lot more people from you know from
the third world but
i mean i think the real motives behind
it uh were even at the beginning
uh you know a calculation by the
democrat party that they were going to
be the political beneficiaries of
greatly expanded immigration
and
uh
there were standards there were efforts
to protect the border obviously even as
recently as bill clinton you know was
concerned about uh protect protecting
the borders but we've very quickly
uh had political power taken over in the
democrat party by
uh you know radicals part of this
radical idiot left-wing ideology that
dominates the democrat party today as a
belief in globalism you know they think
uh
and
and the seeds of globalism uh you know
didn't start with joe biden or or in
recent times but the concept of
globalism really goes uh goes
has a long history
but really a a concept of globalism and
internationalism uh you know uh you know
at least as far back as the aftermath of
world war ii but before that that's why
the united nations was established
that's why we have world court uh you
know that's why we established nato and
then the european union came along uh
you know in academia the not concept of
the nation state got a got a bad
reputation as a consequence of world war
one and world war ii oh nationalism and
patriotism these things result in wars
and uh so we need to create a global
citizen people who identify with a a one
world order you know and go beyond the
nation state and the the league of
nations was an early attempt to do that
uh the united nations uh was an attempt
to do that
they would never the the elites uh and
the globalist elites who uh believed in
this philosophy uh
never explained that as the reason to
the american people because that would
be extremely unpopular you know of
americans throughout most of our history
have been patriotic and don't think
nationalism is evil and it isn't
uh you know uh uh but we've all we
fought a lot of wars in the name of
globalism all right but we had haven't
been explained to us that way that's why
the united states has been all over the
middle east you know engaged in wars
where you were it's almost it's very
hard to find a of an american national
interest all right that is justified for
example by the afghanistan war you know
where we've had people there for a long
time
um
and
uh so part of this is an attempt to it's
not just the idea of having no standards
to let people in but it's an attempt to
erase national boundaries and to
eliminate the nation state as the
organizing principle for for the world
order
uh
and uh and uh that that's why the
administration you know uh uh you know
basically does not protect our border
and it and talk about standards we have
like no standards i mean uh and uh
you know the the border is wide open um
uh you know so uh
you know that's where we are
but i agree with you certainly and and
throughout most of our immigration
history until recent days i mean even
including up until the clinton
administration you know we were supposed
to have standards and we were supposed
to be bringing in people who would make
a net contribution to the society and
immigration policy was supposed to
advance the interests of the american
people who are living here and help make
all of our lives better i was under that
impression so let's talk about russia
if i may because
as you're saying this i'm thinking
there's nobody more nationalistic
that has american pride as this
immigrant right here right
born in iran made in america and i found
that seems to be true with most
immigrants they're lucky to be here
they're happy to be here
like one of the conversations you have
with immigrants is you have no idea what
it's like over there in cuba in
venezuela in north korea with our friend
uh
yomi park i mean we've we've interviewed
these people you have no idea what's
going on over there so it you're talking
about the immigration policies it seems
to me
that it's the
americans who are born here
that are the ones who are a little
anti-american if you will the the far
left of the uh democratic party they're
the ones in my estimation they're the
ones basically saying oh like we're the
bad people we're the bad guys they're
kind of been indoctrinated or ingrained
into this school of thought where the
immigrants are like dude you have no
idea what it's like out there could you
speak to that a little bit what are your
thoughts on naturally born american
citizens being a little more
anti-american than even the immigrants
you're referring to
probably a lot more anti-american than
the immigrants that they're referring to
those people who have experienced living
in authoritarian or totalitarian regimes
you know of course really appreciate
this country they've had in their own
lives the experience of what the
alternative is whereas
americans especially american college
students you know tend to come from very
comfortable middle class they've all
they've never had
had to live under a totalitarian regime
uh or an authoritarian regime uh you
know don't appreciate this country and
our educational system uh you know uh
from the high school level all the way
up uh you know has been has a as a has
become a big brainwashing machine for
leftist views which includes
anti-americanism
uh
i remember when i was uh in graduate
school i mean uh and this was back in
the 1980s
uh
uh you know i had the experience i mean
anti-americanism was basically being
taught back then even then and what year
was that oh uh this was uh
1983
sometime 1980 the early
1980s was taught in universities at this
point oh yeah yeah i mean uh the the
there were there were some conservative
professors at that point but the general
uh uh attitude was
well to give you an example
reading in a uh in in one of our
in one of our courses
uh his history's literature uh you know
was uh eldridge cleavers solon ice okay
uh cleaver was a black panther uh you
know violent activist
anti-american he wanted to
uh uh
overthrow the government of the united
states and establish you know uh
you know a black
nation a separate black nation uh uh in
the old confederacy okay and uh and and
his soul his soul on ice book is a as a
diatribe against the racist evil america
and i remember challenging the professor
who was teaching that book because this
was you know eldridge cleaver's views
trying to introduce us i said you know
how come we're not reading uh uh how
we're not re come we're not reading soul
on fire
you know because uh
uh cleaver you know uh uh you know after
uh
i think he shot a cop or something like
that uh or committed some crime uh but
he uh he he escaped and uh and spent
many years uh living in russia cuba
uh you know uh uh
you know i don't think it went to china
but basically uh authoritarian and
totalitarian regimes
and then he went to the u.s embassy and
and begged to come back to the united
states and uh and when the complaint and
even if he had spent ser
served jail time okay
uh and when he got off the plane he
kissed the tarmac kissed the
literally kissed the ground at the
united states became a christian
uh you know uh and eventually ran as a
republican member of congress in los
angeles you know lost but his his soul
on ice you know is a warning to people
who used to believe as he did that
america is the greatest country on earth
that we should all be grateful here and
they did not teach that okay what did a
professor say that that he had no he
didn't even know the book existed okay
uh you know but how did you know it
existed uh i can't remember how i know
it uh knew it existed this guy was
reading nuclear physicist books at age
three
but there's a lot of books out there for
him to know it like is you know yeah
just curious i read a lot of books yeah
i was very obviously when i was young
and uh and uh but but that if any uh and
i'll bet you that soul on ice is still
required reading but they don't require
them they don't even tell them about the
existence of the other books solo on
fire you know where else cleaver had the
experience of what it was like to live
outside of america and changed his mind
and and just completely reversed course
yeah i just i just pulled it up right
now but what a perspective that you have
with that but let's let's continue let's
go into some of these topics your
expertise so
if the average person turns on the tv
and wants to know more about what's
going on with ukraine and russia they
would probably say
zielinski is a hero they would consider
him churchill
uh
putin is the next hitler
they would say putin is sick he's weak
uh ukraine is beating and winning the
war
uh america is doing a great job giving
all this support to ukraine and getting
involved
uh
it's it's a great job we're doing taking
care of these guys everybody wants to go
have
a meeting with zielinski just a couple
days ago jill biden was in ukraine
having a private meeting with
zielinski's wife first lady
and trudeau was just there from canada
spending some time with zielinski it is
it is becoming a and the world is
getting behind zilinski
now as a person that's extremely
paranoid and let's add a new word to my
vocabulary suspicious right
i'm sitting there and i'm wondering is
there something i don't know that was
one of the reasons why we wanted to
bring you here because i want to see
maybe you got a different perspective
that we don't see
when you see what the news is saying
when you see what's going on
do you see putin getting weaker
do you see him sitting there or do you
see saying
he's doing exactly what he was expecting
america to get into this to use this as
an excuse to create a war against u.s
and american people are not thinking the
negative side effects of what could
happen with us the next 3 6 12 24 months
i don't know what is your perspective
how do you view what's going on versus
the rest of the world okay
well first i i do think zielinski is a
churchill like character
because his job is supposed to be to
convince other countries to come to the
defense of ukraine even if it's not in
their interests i mean that's what
churchill did with the united states in
world war ii and that's what zielinski
is doing now he's supposed to be doing
that so that doesn't make him an evil
person
putin may well be hitler okay
but uh but you have to but you have to
uh putin may be well be stalin all right
but during world war ii we made common
cause with stalin against the con
against the common threat which was nazi
germany
and in my view of the
the west seems to have come completely
forgotten the strategic big picture here
and the big strategic big picture is
that we face
the free
countries uh face
the greatest
threat to our security to our existence
that we have ever faced in the alliance
that exists between russia and china and
their client states north korea and iran
in international terrorism all of whom
are part of a new bloc
you know they haven't formalized it
with a treaty for all of them although
there are treaties between russia and
china and the west has been so slow to
wake up to this reality
uh you know only now
uh uh i bet i've been saying for many
years that russia and china are de facto
allies and it should seems to me it
should have been obvious to anyone you
know who had been following the history
of the relations between russia and
china uh china's
uh
superpower capabilities are built on
russian technology you know uh
the uh uh their their new missiles uh
you know their their advanced aircraft
their ships and everything uh you know
russia basically helped build china into
the great military uh threat that it is
today it's likewise with north korea you
know
has it's amazing to me that washington
never seemed to be
as surprised as it should be that north
korea you know could go
so rapidly
to acquire atomic weapons then the
hydrogen bomb
last december to displace the uh the
world's largest mobile icbm uh that
people think is going to carry mervs now
which is called multiple independently
targeted rancho vehicles so one missile
can send many independent how could
north korea do that all by itself well
it hasn't done it all by itself its
missile technology has been provided to
it by russia and china they want north
korea to pull them to become a nuclear
threat to the united states
so they can fight a proxy nuclear war
against us if they have to uh to uh
drive us out of the pacific by raising
the risks of providing our alliance
guarantees to our allies in the pacific
uh uh you know so that we to change our
strategic calculus to say well you know
if we defend south korea we might get in
a nuclear war with north korea is it
worth the candle if we defend japan
japan is it worth the candle to risk los
angeles and a nuclear war with north
korea likewise with iran you know the
iranian nuclear program the the uh those
are russian nuclear reactors that were
built for them the russians are building
more nuclear reactors the north koreans
missiles are based on usually based on
north korean technology their best
medium range missile the shahab 3 is
really a souped-up version of north
korea's nodong and there are north
korean scientists and technicians and
russian and chinese scientists and
technicians in iran helping them develop
their nuclear missile programs so they
are have been a clandestine
block okay now finally washington
has seized that oh russia and china
really are allies they've been hoping
that that hasn't been true for for many
years right up until the ukrainian
crisis but they are allies and our
job number one for us you know is is to
be prepared to defeat this
block this totalitarian power block
uh that is coming you know they are a
bigger threat to us by far than nazi
german in the imperial japan world world
war ii you know because they can destroy
our homeland now did you just say
they're a bigger threat oh yeah the nazi
in germany was in world war the nazi
germany and imperial japan combined and
fascist steadily combined because the
those the totalitarian powers of that
day could not reach across the oceans
they couldn't project power across the
ocean now they can and they could
destroy our society in 30 minutes and
all their even even their allies and we
should by the way when a country gets
nuclear missiles you really need to
think of them as a superpower you know
we like to think of superpowers as
you know meeting an economic definition
when it comes to life and death what
matters is can that country destroy you
and can they do it quickly north korea
could destroy us and it could do it
quickly that makes them a superpower
even though the rest of their economy in
no other respect are they a superpower
but it doesn't matter when it comes to
life and death they are a superpower and
iran i believe is already a superpower i
think that we've
it's another topic i just published a uh
a report today as a matter of fact it
was uh you know carried in uh in israel
called iran emp threat where i make the
case that iran has already got nuclear
weapons that they've had them for some
time i'm not the only one who believes
that you know there's a uh
you know a very credible minority view
in the american strategic community that
never gets heard okay that says hey iran
has already got the bomb but this is the
most formidable combination we've ever
faced in our history and i don't think
we can beat it you know if we have to
end up having a protracted
new cold war against this combination
we're going to lose and if it goes into
a hot war we're going to lose even worse
all right so our job number one
you know
is to split the russian chinese alliance
that's our best hope for prevailing in
the new cold war that is our highest
priority to split that alliance
and uh uh
and i i think it's possible to do it uh
you know because i think putin uh and
russia has been discontented with that
alliance i think they understand russia
is smart enough to see that china in the
long run
after they defeat us okay there's going
to be a world war iv between the
totalitarian powers and i think
russia realizes because of the
they've built up china to be such a
strong power
and they have a billion people
that china in the long run is a bigger
threat to russia than the west is
uh and the uh the uh uh i also think
russia is kind of disappointed
in its relationship with china china is
obviously on their side now and they're
getting benefits from china now but the
relative benefits that have come from
this relationship have much more favored
china than russia in terms of economic
benefits in terms of technology transfer
in terms of geostrategic influence i
think
putin was waiting
for
trump to hit the reset button and it was
general flynn's plan his national
security advisor even wrote a book about
it to say you know what we've got to do
is hit the reset button with russia to
split the russian chinese alliance and
putin was just waiting for that to
happen but the democrat party made it
impossible to happen because of these
false charges that
trump was putin's puppet and so he never
got a chance to hit hit the reset button
and the democrat party has gone on with
this mantra about russia russia russia
being the uh you know being evil and uh
and and
and now over the ukraine war uh you know
uh how uh he's a war criminal so how
could we make common cause with them and
all
all of that and the focus is on
on defeating russia and the ukraine war
and uh
uh
we're not going to be able to defeat
russia in the ukraine war i mean there's
just so much to talk about here because
if russia has to they will resort to
nuclear weapons chemical and biological
weapons they've cheated on the chemical
and biological weapons treaties they
have very sophisticated offensive
chemical and biological weapons they've
cheated on all the arms control treaties
and yes i'm starry state department i
think they've cheated on the new start
treaty too it's the last treaty that
they're supposed to be obeying okay
which is it controls the strategic
warheads that can reach us you know i
think they probably have cheated on new
start as well and they have a huge
advantage there we and that we know
they've got a 10 to one advantage at
least in tactical nuclear weapons they
probably have a two to one advantage in
strategic nuclear weapons and they have
the world's most advanced
passive and active
strategic defenses you know there are
thousands of of shelters and bunkers
hundreds of deep underground facilities
for the russian political military
leadership they can they can protect the
top 300 000 political military leaders
in russia in deep underground facilities
that are under hundreds of meters of
granite that are impervious to nuclear
attack that's where putin was uh i think
it was on february 27th when he put his
forces on nuclear alert uh there are
thousands probably ten thousands of
thousands of shelters for the general
population uh back in 2016 russia had a
civil defense exercise that mobilized 40
million people to practice a nuclear
protecting their population against the
nuclear war the subways and the major
cities have blast doors so people can go
down in the subways and be protected we
have nothing like that we have nothing
you know we have no civil defense
serious civil defense program in this
country we have
our whole national missile defense
comprises 64 ground-based interceptors
based in alaska and northern kelp and
they're designed not to intercept
russian or chinese icbms they're meant
to
to to deal with low technology icbms
that we thought would come out of north
korea or iran
and we've been fooled because the nor
their north korean icbms are actually
much more sophisticated because they're
based on russian and chinese technology
i mean think about this for where north
korea is concerned there's only three
countries in the world that have mobile
icbms you know how complicated a mobile
icbm is i mean that's basically cape
canaveral on wheels to be able to carry
a intercontinental ballistic missile and
have all the targeting and command and
control assets in a truck okay to launch
that icbm very sophisticated thing
there's only three countries in the
world that have mobile icbms russia
china north korea we don't have mobile
icbms you know but north korea does what
does that tell you
in terms of you know who helped them uh
get where they are and uh so we've got
only got those 64 gbis they've got 10
000
uh anti-missile and uh anti-aircraft
10 000 nuclear and conventional capable
uh uh you know a very dense national
missile defense surrounding russia uh
you know uh uh you know that to shoot
down our our warheads to shoot down our
bombers to shoot down our cruise
missiles so
uh they are much better prepared
and all their nuclear forces 90 of them
are modern and high-tech and advanced uh
they have weapons systems that we don't
even have in our arsenal like super emp
weapons and weapons that are specialized
for x-ray effects and neutrons ultra low
yield nuclear weapons that could
you know be just five
have very low yield enough to take out a
bridge or enough to take out the
pentagon and not break the windows of
neighboring of [ __ ] of of of neighboring
buildings uh very high yield weapons
like the poseidon they could have a a
weapon that could be have a yield that
is as high as 200 megatons you know
which is something like twenty thousand
times the power of the hiroshima bomb
you know
uh
we don't have
weapons like that in our inventory and
in fact joe biden is retiring nuclear
weapons for the best some of our best
nuclear weapons he's he's cancelled the
silicon n which is a nuclear-armed
cruise missile
that was desperately needed to restore
the balance where tactical nuclear
weapons was concerned you know because
we have almost no tactical nuclear
weapons and the silica man is gone he
took it out of his budget and uh and
he's retired the b83 which was our best
it was the last megaton class nuclear
weapon we had in our inventory 1.2
megatons it's the only nuclear weapon we
have that has a chance of generating a
shock wave that's powerful enough to to
to
perhaps damage some of those deep
underground facilities where the bad
guys in north korea and china and russia
can hide you know and uh and it's gone
uh you know so he's taken that away so
we're building down while the others are
are building up and uh uh but this
lengthy disposition on uh the nuclear
balance is a reason why we should not
get involved in ukraine war uh you know
i think we should be pulling back not uh
not not going forward because we cannot
win a nuclear war with russia you know
uh you know and and and and if we
if what we're hearing
on and is true the narrative that's
coming across on the tv and the russia's
really on the ropes and the putin is
crazy and and uh and uh and uh and he
may fall from power
uh uh then we're very close to the
nuclear brink closer than we were during
the cuban missile crisis and our
policies are creating a situation where
we will get into a nuclear war and lose
it you know but i
uh i know because you've you know you've
been re reading my stuff that i uh
you know i'm not convinced that that is
the reality uh this is what we're being
told uh you know but i'm not uh
convinced that that's the reality there
are other realities not all of them
mutually exclusive uh may i continue i
know please okay uh
uh for one thing i i you know i john
bolton wrote a a a pretty good article
for gatestone recently that's a good
corrective to a lot of the nonsense we
we hear uh and why why is it why do i
say that a lot of what we're hearing on
the news is nonsense because almost
everything we know about what's going on
in the ukraine war is coming from the
ukrainians
you know uh you know and from the biden
administration but mostly from the
ukrainians and the ukrainian government
has an interest in convincing the west
that they're winning and the russians
are under ropes and it'll be really easy
to defeat the russians in ukraine if
we'll just come in okay and so naturally
everything that they tell us is designed
to convince us that that is true and the
bible administration is uh has an equal
political interest in convincing that is
true
because they want the russians to look
as bad as possible in ukraine so that
the narrative will not be
that biden basically
experienced a defeat and humiliation
even greater than afghanistan
when he drew the red line over ukraine
for russia and russia just rolled its
tanks across it you know he basically
put america and the in the west nato's
credibility on the line
in ukraine and blew it you know all
those decades of trying to build up
nato's credibility and u.s credibility
decades of it among successive
presidents was all thrown away by joe
biden when he promised when he
warned putin not to invade ukraine and
he did it anyway
biden doesn't want the conversation to
be about that because this is a
humiliation and a foreign policy
disaster that is ten thousands of times
worse than afghanistan and so let the
conversation be about how the russians
are losing so badly and the worse the
russians look the better that is for
biden
so i'm not sure we can trust what we're
seeing
you know the fog of war is always very
thick in wars i i'd remind the american
people
you know two wars you know the war in
vietnam
where right up until 1968 you know
all
all most americans were convinced we
were winning the war we were going to
win the war okay until the north vietnam
launched the 1968 tent offensive and uh
you know and and all these promises from
general westmoreland that we had killed
all the uh all of the viet cong turned
out to be un untrue and that we our
intelligence was all wrong about about
how close we were to victory and
it was just a la a year ago okay that
that we've had the debacle in
afghanistan
where we did have boots on the ground
for many many years we weren't relying
on ukrainians we were relying on our own
intelligence agencies and our own best
experts in the defense department to
give the us the assessment that
don't worry about afghanistan we can
have an honorable withdrawal
and uh and we could have a government
that will at least temporarily be
friendly to the united states and uh and
uh and moderate in its views and all of
that turned out to be false you know our
assessment of the uh and uh our
assessment of the reality on the ground
in afghanistan turned out to be
completely completely false
so
we don't have a good record long term or
short term in terms of making accurate
assessments about what's happening
happening on the ground uh it could be
that our whole assessment of
of what putin's objectives were in
ukraine may be wrong
uh you know we've assumed because we are
the west and we believe in fighting
quick
wars you know we don't like portray war
at all and we want them to be quick and
surgical and that's how we fight war and
because ukraine isn't going that way we
may say oh this is just a disaster for
putin maybe not
uh
you know the russian way of war can be
that way that for example uh you know as
bolton correctly points out uh you know
uh putin may have thought that invading
ukraine would go the way it did when he
took crimea all right which was
basically a blitzkrieg type thing and he
took it quickly and bloodlessly but
there's another model to look at on the
ground that was happening in ukraine in
eastern ukraine you know there had been
this long bloody uh war of attrition
going on in donetsk and lahansk eastern
ukraine for eight years you know and
that's another russian way of war and in
fact
most of russian military history you
know is not
quick clean decisive victories mostly
it's a against the mongols against the
swedes against napoleon world war one
and world war ii you know it's a
grinding bloody
you know you use mass and attrition to
just eventually wear your enemy down and
that's how you win wars uh and they're
and they're ruthless and uh uh they're
fought like a totalitarian inhumane
power not
you know
the way
democracies do where we're very humane
in terms of where we try to be you know
in terms of the way we wage our wars
and uh and that's
uh and and it may have been putin's
intention all along uh and i'm not
saying he didn't suffer setbacks and all
the rest you know certainly there
there has been that
but maybe ukraine's chief objective
wasn't
uh you know the liberation of ukraine
and the takeover of ukraine that's one
of his objectives surely but another it
may be that having the war is one of his
objectives
military dictatorships having the war
with who with us uh with anyone but with
uh with with well let's start with
ukraine just having a war is a good
thing from the point of view of a
military dictatorship in an
authoritarian state because it it it
rallies the people behind you shows
strength it it shows strength to your
population it rallies the people behind
you you know they're the russian people
are being told this isn't just a war
against ukrainian nazis but it's against
nato and the united states nato and the
united states are attacking us through
ukraine so if you're concerned about
your political power i mean putin's
obviously has shored up his base by
having this war by rallying the public
behind him at a time when he was you
know suffering economically because of
sanctions and stuff like that it's
driven up the price of oil which is in
natural gas which is great for russia uh
you know it's uh uh arms sales are
another great source of russian income
you know and uh uh but isn't it also
tearing apart the russian economy they
can't all be just be good things from
this war
you constantly see the bad things that
are happening to the russian economy the
ruble has crumbled the oligarchs are
fleeing from the country they have no
money or access to the money they've
shut down the payment system the what's
the payment system called
uh the swift payment so it's not like
all these good things are happening
because of this saying it's all good
sure there are some negative things but
spoken like a man of the west
you know to to
to put economics you know is which is
all the way we calculate what is the
cost
is the standard of living going down you
know to us uh you know that's what
matters most you know but to a russian
you know the the people in the streets
people who support uh support putin what
matters is survival you know the uh that
uh it is within the living memory of
many russians and they learn in their
schools that they lost 30 million dead
that's just the dead those aren't the
casualties you know from world war ii
for them
the idea of survival and not being taken
by surprise and not having another
destruction of their country is as far
outweighs
the what the oligarchs may be suffering
in terms of their lifestyles being set
back uh the other thing is that war uh
the chaos of war uh
just comforts the west and uh it uh you
know we don't because we don't like it
uh and it makes us insecure
uh uh especially if you end up with a
protracted war and bolton in his article
in gatestone talks about a 30 to 100
year war to take over ukraine okay
uh
uh you know 32 100 year war to take over
ukraine yes that's the in the title of
his uh gates of his gatestone article
maybe he doesn't mean that literally but
i can imagine it there have been such
wars in history the 30 years war the
hundred years war over france nations
which we
you know we think world war ii is a long
war but if you look at how long wars
have lasted some places they go on for
years and years uh you know decades even
uh the recent war between azerbaijan and
armenia that was settled in favor of the
israelites went on for 30 years the
nagano karabakh war okay uh you know
this is not on you that not untypical
it's unusual for our
experience and uh
the benefit of a long war from the point
of view of the bad guys is that we
always want peace this thing we call
peace and so after a while we will end
up coming to the table to say how can we
resolve this and then the benefits will
flow as they
have done in the past you know uh you
know so that's one possibility maybe uh
you know maybe putin's calculation what
is
have a
protracted period of war just the way he
did in eastern ukraine for eight years i
mean he could have resolved that uh he
had in fact the uh
the european union uh and uh and merkel
met with putin to try to resolve the
east europe
that war that was going on for eight
years okay so he sort of experienced
that that even that little war going on
in eastern ukraine managed to get the
discomforted nato enough that it got us
to a negotiating table to talk about
resolving it but he he had no intentions
of resolving it you know so maybe this
is just the uh the uh the the long
protracted grinding war that he had
going on in eastern ukraine writ large
dr brian question question for you sure
what what is the best
defense right now i know you said hey
let's uh we have to figure out a way to
split some of those relationship with
china and russia we got to get strong we
can't get these two powerhouses you know
uniting because if china and russia and
iran are on the same team
we're screwed i mean
what can you do if you got those three
guys that are on the same team russia
china just signed a 30-year contract
with iran for what 400 billion so iran
is now linked with china
and china and russia are neighbors if
they kind of team up and say hey look
america's the top enemy you hate them we
hate them let's figure out a way to kind
of weaken them this is a great
opportunity for us to do so
aside from trying to split up what else
is the best defense we can defense we
can play
could i just
walk through other possible scenarios in
terms of what might be going on in
ukraine and then i'll uh answer that
question you know another scenario here
and i'll i'll try to do it quickly uh
you know is uh i think of the spanish
civil war scenario you know if if if if
putin aspires to global domination
you know which i think he may
uh
uh
he may want to test his weapons his
tactics and blood his troops the way
hitler did during world war ii during
the spanish civil war before the blitz
creek was unleashed on the west you know
they tested it out tested out the troops
the generals
in the spanish civil war
that way you can find out you know who
are the good generals who are the bad
generals you know put the best people in
charge which tactics work which don't
how can we improve weapons and things
like that you so ukraine could be a big
laboratory experiment you know for this
sort of thing and last is the the uh
battle of australis scenario the uh uh
the uh napoleon's greatest victory in
not 1805 which is uh much studied in the
russian general staff it should be
studied in all academies uh
you know in 1805
uh and i don't say this is likely it's
just a possibility all right uh uh you
know napoleon faced the combined
uh
uh armies of the the greatest land
powers of europe in 1805. uh he had
marched his army from paris all the way
into central europe uh by forced marches
and uh
the uh
uh
you know they were still afraid to
attack him the combined powers of russia
austria and prussia you know because
napoleon had such a great reputation as
a as a great general uh you know but he
had a plan to defeat all of these guys
even though i was he was greatly
outnumbered but he just needed to
convince them to attack him you know to
walk into his trap
and uh so he did this by having
defectors go over to the russians and
the austrians and say oh the french army
is really demoralized we've all we're
overextended we're so far from paris
we're exhausted from these long marches
he had whole regiments run away from the
russians in the field to convince them
that the french army all they had to do
was attack to defeat him he he
deliberately took the weakest part the
worst part of the battlefield okay so
they had the high ground you know so
everything looked perfect for defeating
napoleon okay and then they attacked and
he dropped the hammer on them uh the
battle ended with this humiliating thing
with the russian army had a retreat out
onto a frozen lake which he broke up
with his cannon and hundreds of them
drowned but uh that's uh
textbook napoleon's greatest victory the
battle of australia was based on on on
convincing the other side that you were
weak that you were on divergent defeat
all you have to do is come in and attack
me and you'll win
and that could be happening in ukraine i
mean
so many of these things that are done
wrong i mean so many fundamentals that
the russians appear to have done wrong
it makes me suspicious that maybe it's
deliberate you know to convince us that
oh these guys are so incompetent you
know let's just jump in there the way
lindsey graham wants us to uh
you know we could find ourselves
if we were to do something like that and
we get more deeply involved in the
ukraine war
that's right at the edge of our ability
to project power
we'll have a deuce of a problem getting
our guys out if we're wrong about that
calculation we're not going to be able
to get them out and uh and uh maybe the
big plan for the general staff is to use
uh the ukraine as the bloodlands again
what a great place for tactical nuclear
weapons to use that ten to one advantage
in tactical nuclear weapons and suddenly
go nuclear with this war and and make
ukraine war could be the final solution
for russia of the problem of nato
and the united states you know by
using their tactical at nuclear
advantage to obliterate us in ukraine
anyway those are other possibilities
that i
beg our policymakers to think about
before we wave more deeply into the
ukraine war to your question what should
we be doing
well what i think we should be doing is
again going back to the big picture we
should be trying to split the russian
chinese alliance okay so we don't have
to contend with this warring block
and what we should do is uh i think we
should be raising the readiness level of
our strategic nuclear forces right now
biden is basically broken precedent back
on i think it was february 27th that
putin put his forces on high alert his
nuclear forces have been high alert
they've been ready for a nuclear war
they've been threatening the nuclear war
every day and we haven't responded you
know in the past when the russians did
something like that we would raise the
def con level that's the readiness level
the lowest level is five you know
and and our forces are
at readiness five right now that makes
us vulnerable to a nuclear pearl harbor
the the bombers are not are you know
could be destroyed on their bases the
most of our ballistic missile submarines
are still in port they could be
destroyed in their bases with just two
warheads you know the icbms are the only
thing that would be ready we've only got
400 icbm warheads you know against an
enormous target set in russia and
they've got hypersonic weapons that
could perhaps you know
destroy those icbms before they could
launch
so
you know what we should do is raise the
def con level
at least to defcon 3 so that our forces
are in a more survivable posture so that
the russians would be less capable of
doing a nuclear pearl harbor and then
immediately communicate to moscow that
look it we're raising the our our forces
to defcon 3 because you guys increased
the alert of your forces and you have
left us no choice we don't plan to
attack you this isn't a plan for a
surprise nuclear attack we want peace
so
let's both sides lower the readiness of
our nuclear forces back to a normal
level and while we're doing that let's
have an immediate cease fire in ukraine
and let's go to the negotiating table
and negotiate a piece based on the peace
treaty that you offered that you moscow
offered to nato and the united states
before you invaded ukraine that peace
treaty the biden administration didn't
even seriously try to negotiate it
there were many points of that treaty
that should have been acceptable to us
not least not having ukraine and nato
and promising not to expand nato further
east it's even more in our interest than
it is russia's interest to not expand
nato even further further to the east so
there are many points in that treaty
that should be acceptable to us the
point of this process is that this could
be a golden opportunity okay to turn
lemons in the lemonade and to hit the
reset button with russia do you think he
would entertain that
i think he would uh i think he would
because uh because in the long run
uh because first i don't think putin's
crazy i don't think he's in a sick bed i
think that putin
had wanted to realign himself with the
west during the trump administration i
think that he sees china as the bigger
long-term threat to us than the west
i think that if he could return to
normalcy certainly his oligarchs would
like it as and you know as you uh uh
pointed out
uh you know so i think that there is a a
significant possibility you know that uh
that we could use this uh and the most
important thing
immediate thing from my point of view is
though the one vital national interest
we have in the ukraine war
is to stop it because of the nuclear
escalatory possibilities this idea that
we can control our involvement in
ukraine and that nothing is going to go
wrong that things are not going to go
off the tracks and and turn into a
nuclear into a nuclear war by accident
or miscalculation is really
unwise frankly
a historical i mean just think of how
world war one started you know a single
bullet fired by a serbian terrorist in
the chest of a archduke blew up into a
nuclear war very qui excuse me into
world war one very quickly uh you know
that killed millions of people uh
ukraine is far more important
strategically than serbia was and the
and the possibilities for escalation
they're enormous we need to get out of
this situation uh you know desperately
uh to avoid this this escala these
escalatory possibilities so there are
two huge u.s national security interests
that would be solved here
terminating the ukraine war so the
escalatory possibilities are ended and
splitting
the uh the russian
chinese alliance so that we have some
kind of a chance to win the new cold war
against china i think i think
putin could be persuaded to become a
neutral at least a neutral but maybe
even a strategic partner to the process
of negotiating and resolving our
conflicting security views
you know i don't think you're going to
be able to
i think it's too much to hope that
russia is going to be contained forever
and they're not going to want to have
their empire back you know that's what
bolton was talking about about the 30 to
100 year war i think bolton is right i
think the russian people not just putin
they want their empire back they want
great russia back and they're going to
fight for 30 to 100 years
diplomatically and militarily if
necessary to do that do we have the
political will to oppose that for thirty
to one i don't think so we don't didn't
even have the political will to defeat
the taliban so let's be realistic about
our foreign policy we're not the global
you know we're not we're not able to
control the whole world and we're not
responsible for controlling the whole
world we're chiefly responsible
to the american people to protecting our
lives protecting this country and
protecting our civilization and this is
as i can see it is the is the as the
quickest way and safest way to uh to end
the ukraine war and to position
ourselves to to win the new cold war by
by achieving the most important
objective right now which would be
should be to split the russia-china
alliance you said you said something
that got me thinking so in your eyes
if you said world war four
for russia is going to be against china
meaning world war iii is going to be us
right
so if let's just say russia does choose
to attack
ukraine
u.s gets involved and russia says screw
this i'm sick and tired of the way us by
administration is handling it i'm
attacking u.s as well done but i'm going
to take a different angle
if he does and let's just say he
succeeds let's go to the succeeding part
he succeeds and it's a debacle here you
know you use the word it's a mess over
here in us
then
whether he likes it or not he has to
face off the last bully that's going to
be stronger than him because he's
getting stronger every year which is
china so it would be a very bad move on
his end
to do anything to u.s because he's going
to need u.s long-term to protect them in
case something happens with china
because china's the guy that's standing
alone by themselves buying up all these
small different places they're
buying the cobalt in uh you know uh
africa they're you know their their
strategy with iran with oil the way
they're taking it is a very different
strategy on how china's taking it
would you say the same thing would you
agree with that that russia needs
america to make sure long-term they're
protected from china
the russians are chess players and i
think that that analysis
is possibly the way the russians are
thinking about this and it's even
possible that
that
one of the reasons they have we haven't
been attacked yet is precisely because
of that that they that they need us in
the long run looking toward world war
four but i wouldn't count on on on
on
that forbearance forever okay you know
uh there's gonna come a point where our
involvement in ukraine if we decide to
go the other way and become more deeply
involved uh you know uh kill more
russian generals kill more russians on
the ground try to for try to defeat
putin in ukraine there's going to come
another place where he says well i've
got to be concerned with my immediate
survival you know and uh and and there's
no hope of negotiating with uh with the
west but let me say this and conclude
another thought on this about the
negotiating the peace with putin uh
through ukraine
what if russia decides not to negotiate
with us
okay that's the other thing
i mean one of the hardest things in
managing foreign policy and defense
policies is is situational awareness
what is our situation via v russia you
know is it possible to to play ball with
them uh the way we did with stalin in
world war two
and if and and
it will tell us so much
if we try to negotiate with putin on the
basis of his own peace treaty and then
he says no deal i don't
uh you know uh this treat that i'm not
even gonna negotiate you with that
treaty because i'm in ukraine now that's
going to tell us
a lot about what this war in ukraine is
really about for putin it will tell us i
believe that uh
that putin is uh is stalin and z is uh
is a hitler in 1939 and ukraine is
poland z meaning g yeah the the dictator
of china yeah and and and and ukraine is
poland all over again and that this is
all part of a plot by these guys okay
that they're unified behind closing yeah
exactly and that they're not worried
about losing in ukraine and uh and that
this is the big move okay that this is
the big move this is 1939 all over again
it's important for us to know that
that's a very good point you just made
so are they maybe waiting
for
you know for us to make the move for
them to say we didn't you know we
reacted to your
behavior you did this and then we had to
go and protect ourselves because you got
involved in something we told you stay
out of this are they almost waiting
for u.s to be aggressive
that that could be the case they could
be wanting the u.s to come into ukraine
uh you know as i said before the
australia scenario right provocative
right
intervene a lot of the things the
atrocities for example almost seemed
calculated to inflame western opinion so
that we'll just on impulse
send our forces in there so that they'll
be destroyed i would also point out to
by the way i mean it really isn't
pointed out uh you know when you look at
the balance of power uh here you know
russia is fighting the ukraine war with
one hand behind its back you know i mean
they've only got 200 000 troops in
ukraine they've got a 2 million man army
they've got 20 000 tanks they only have
you know for 4 000 tanks or so the air
force has hardly played that significant
role the air force's has really held
back uh it's really it's
inc it's either incredibly gross
incompetence which is what we're being
told or something else is going on here
in terms of holding back all this power
and uh uh i think it's time for us to be
less dysfunctionally optimistic and a
little more paranoid before we get uh go
forward and think about
if we're wrong again here the way we
were in afghanistan and the way we were
in vietnam what's the worst that could
happen and the worst could happen is the
destruction of the west if we play this
thing all wrong well let's get into that
and i don't want to take that chance
especially you know we need time well
yeah i'll just transition into that
because i i want to i want to go into
that which is
you know a most most the average person
is like oh my god i want a nuclear war
what if there's a nuclear war what
happens how bad is it how you know ugly
is it going to get if the somebody does
something like that like truman did back
in the days when we responded back to
pearl harbor all this other stuff okay
fine for you what concerns you more
nuclear war cyber warfare biochemical
warfare or a super emp type of attack
that you know i i read this somewhere
that says experts say our power grid can
be destroyed and when that happens
seven or ninety percent of u.s
population will die within the first
year
which of those four concerns you the
most
well i i put
super emp and cyber together uh you know
my in my book blackout warfare i
described this revolutionary new way of
warfare that is in the military
doctrines
of russia china north korea and iran and
they are prepared to execute this
where
the focus of the attack is
national electric grids okay because we
are an electronic civilization
and uh and uh everything all of our
life-sustaining critical infrastructures
communications transportation even food
and water
uh depend upon electricity
and uh the military the ability to
project power and operate your military
forces and command and control all
depends upon electricity
so the theory of this
you know is uh is that if you can take
out the electric grids with emp attacks
and cyber warfare and special forces
sabotage small numbers of guys going in
and shooting up transformers and stuff
uh you know you'll cause a nationwide
blackout and that will bring the other
side to its knees and you'll basically
win a war and
very quickly potentially at the speed of
light you know because of the way emp
and cyber work and not
and because it's
uh uh
even a new what so-called nuclear emp
attack is not
a hiroshima attack a nagasaki type use
of an atomic bomb it's not considered
nuclear war in russian or chinese north
korean doctrines considered part of
cyber warfare electronic warfare and
rightly so because of the way the
physics work you know you detonate a
weapon
at a very high altitude 300 400
kilometers it's so high that if you were
standing on the ground directly beneath
the explosion you wouldn't even hear it
i mean it's 300 400 kilometers over your
head going off in the vacuum of space
there wouldn't even be a noise all right
the the blast wouldn't reach you that
there'd be no thermal or radioactive
effects that would reach you the only
thing that would come down would be the
electromagnetic pulse which is harmless
to people it passes harmlessly through
your body like a radio wave but it will
destroy electronics cars won't work you
won't have any water because it required
the electric grid would collapse and
requires millions and volts to get water
food would start spoiling you know
there's only enough food to feed people
at three days in local grocery stores
and in the whole of the united states we
only have enough food to supply people
for 30 days 330 million people for 30
days at normal consumption rates and it
would begin to a spoil immediately and
it couldn't be transported to market
because
the interstate highways would be jammed
transportation systems wouldn't work
in effect
it's a way of subtracting from modern
electronic civilization
you know the technologies that make life
possible today
and uh
a president faced with that you know
wouldn't be able to operate his forces
you might not even be
able to retaliate with a super emp
weapon because it would fry the
electronics and command and control
systems and the missiles and the bombers
and
faced with do i go and fight a losing
war in ukraine or do i mobilize what is
left of the defense department to try to
restore the electric grid to save
millions of american lives before people
start starving to death and society
collapses obviously
that ladder choice and that's part of
their calculation and we're even closer
to that i'm most concerned about that
scenario because before russia goes
nuclear in terms of the classical
nuclear war where they would blow up
icbms in their silos or or
or attack bomber bases with nuclear
weapons or or even do tactical nuclear
strikes in ukraine you know uh you know
i think it's more likely that they would
use
what i call a blackout war you know
because this is
it it would kill very few people
initially it's a uh it's a uh it's
what's called gray zone aggression you
know uh it it it's a non-traditional way
of warfare that we really have no way of
responding to and it could be
very quick and very decisive uh and to
solve the problem without having to go
to a large-scale nuclear exchange
so i think
you know we're even closer to that than
we are to a nuclear war and i think it
very likely that they would exercise
that option before they went before they
went nuclear how tough is it to build an
emp
any nuclear weapon that
will generate an electromagnetic pulse
but uh there are also non-nuclear emp
weapons that would be part of this
scenario
the us air force has one called champ
it's basically a cruise missile and it
carries a non-nuclear emp generator
and uh it doesn't generate a field as
big as a nuclear weapon i mean a single
nuclear weapon is really all you'd need
to block take out the whole us electric
grid detonated at very high altitude but
with a couple of dozen maybe 20 of these
cruise missiles or drones carrying
non-nuclear electromagnetic pulse
generators they would follow the power
lines and uh it would take hours instead
of uh a second uh you know but they
could achieve the same thing and and and
black out the power grid
countries like iran
uh and even terrorist groups are capable
of of of harnessing non-nuclear emp
weapons and using them in this way they
have the sophistication to do that so
it's not hard at all as a matter of fact
if you had the money you can actually
buy emp devices not intended to be used
as weapons but they could be could be
used as weapon there's a
device called the emp suitcase that
looks just like a suitcase it's designed
to be operated and carried by one man
it puts out a hundred thousand volts
hundred thousand volts per meter over a
short distance a hundred yards that
right there yes that's it uh and how
much does something like that go for i
think fifty thousand okay it's not a lot
of money not for a terrorist group or a
nation state but if you had
a a a terrorist or a criminal or a
disgruntled individual got one of those
things and he put it in the chunk of his
car and he drove up to an extra high
voltage power substation i mean you see
these when you drive down the highway
all the time you know we've arrived at a
place technologically where a single
individual could topple the pillars
technological pillars of civilization
for an entire metropolitan area like
miami or new york or boston just by
himself just with that and if you had it
just with that yeah and if you had a
team of guys running around the country
you could black out the whole national
electric grid just just with these
devices how come it's not happened yet
well
it has happened in chechnya and other
places uh it hasn't happened in this
country yeah well give them time
you know uh
uh
it uh you know i don't know why it
hasn't happened yet we've been lucky you
know uh uh the great german statesman
otto von bismarck once said you know god
looks after uh uh fools drunkards little
children in the united states of america
maybe that's why it hasn't happened but
has anyone been caught attempting to do
something of this capacity we've uh we
haven't caught somebody with the rf
briefcase yet but we have caught uh you
know
actually i haven't called the person but
there was a uh
a drone in pennsylvania uh somebody flew
a drone now uh you know
you know that try to make a different
kind of an attack against the power line
i'm not sure i
want to get into all the technical
details there was an incident uh
a few not too long ago uh that happened
in uh canada uh where a disgruntled
individual
used it wasn't a radio frequency weapon
but it was a different technology even
simpler
that enabled him to black out
temporarily the hydroquebec
grid in canada put millions of people
into the dark uh you know they did
correct it after a day but one guy did
that and uh so there have been attacks
on electric grids here in north america
uh there were attacks in the electric
grid in mexico by the uh back in 2013
yeah uh
uh the knights templars they're a drug
cartel
uh
they used explosives and small arms to
attack uh to black out the electric grid
in the province of mexico they put about
a half million people into dark so that
they could go into the towns and
villages and publicly execute people who
were opposed to the drugs trade the the
village elders and leaders who were
opposed to the drug trade you know so if
neanderthals like the knights templars
have figured out that the electric grid
is a keystone societal vulnerability
just think what al qaeda or isis or
north korea and these much more
sophisticated actors could do we're very
lucky i mean i was kind of surprised
when isis was on the ropes that they
didn't just pay the knights templars to
come across the border i mean you know
and say hey go do go to the united
states which you guys did in mexico
we've been i i think the reason we had
it has hasn't happened yet is because
we've been lucky these guys are from
michoacan they're michoacan yeah
that was the province that i know a lot
of people from each other
we've got to keep an eye on them yeah
good friends by the way going back to
this so you know what i would do if i
was that if i was a us government
i would buy that company
who sells those suitcases
everybody that buys it they would be on
alert
that's exactly what i would do yeah
there's no way in the world i'm going to
let that stay
without i'd overpay to find out who the
hell is doing this i'd go into
partnership and figure out i have a cia
guy we'll have working for that company
point out so i don't get sued
but that has legitimate peaceful
purposes they don't intend it to be used
as a weapon oh i'm not worried about
there's there's guns that are intended
to peaceful purposes in the wrong guy's
hand that's the one thing exactly it's
it's potentially a weapon of mass how do
you use that for peaceful purposes and
you don't even need a license to buy it
unlike a gun you need a license to buy a
gun but you can buy that without a
license how is that used for peaceful
purposes well yeah you know if you're
designing an airport for example okay
okay and you want to know how far away
do i have to put the runway so that the
radars don't fry the electronics and
airplanes when you're landing
you can use a device like that to
simulate the pulse that's coming off the
radar to see how far things have to be
spaced or if you're laying out if you've
got a factory and it's got a lot of
heavy electronic equipment drill presses
metal bending equipment stuff that uses
a lot of electricity they put out
powerful electromagnetic transients and
this kind of equipment is spaced too
closely together they can fry each other
and commit fatracide okay so you need to
know how far apart how thick does the
shielding have to be and that's what
it's intended to be used for you know to
to help you
you know you don't want to have to move
the equipment in and learn by by
experience you know how far apart should
i have put the drill presses and things
like that you know that that's what it's
intended
for so it has it does have a legitimate
uh legitimate purpose but perhaps uh
you know the uh but perhaps it should be
licensed then we should have better
control
yeah and perhaps no
just anybody shouldn't be able to
purchase and we're but we're not the
only ones i mean this is a us company
there's a german company that sells
sells they saying i'm sure terrorists
already have them and terrorists have
used them in chechnya you asked why
hasn't happened here the chechen
terrorists figured out how to use them
against the russians russians and in
chechnya they used to
to kill the electronics so they can go
in and kill everybody in a in a military
base let me ask you a question earlier
you were talking about nuclear shelter
so i pulled up a couple numbers here
israel has nuclear shelters i think
sweden has like 63 000 or something
nuclear shelters a lot of different
countries have nuclear
shelters so
if we whether that is something we have
or not it's definitely not talked about
openly amongst people do we have nuclear
shelters in
cities and communities where if
something were to happen here's what we
have
fibo would probably say we do okay but
there's an enormous difference between
what we've uh what
you know what fema did you know back
when we had a
a significant civil defense program
you've probably seen those civil defense
signs you know the the radioactive
symbol
sometimes they'll be in the basement of
a library or something like that that's
what our shelter is you know
those aren't the kinds of shelters
they've got in russia okay these are uh
you know these are not
serious shelters that are designed
to to survive uh you know a nuclear war
they are they will provide you it's
better than nothing i mean it's better
to be in the shelter of a library okay
if a nuclear blast happens uh or if
there's radioactive fallout coming down
so you don't get directly exposed to it
but we don't have anything like what the
russians have got
in the intelligence community they're
called deep underground shelters or
doug's all right i'm talking about uh
you know some of the more famous ones
are chekhov and sharapova kazavinsky
mountain yamato mountain these are
shelters that are
hundreds of meters deep on solid granite
they're impervious to nuclear attack is
that is that a form of a shelter right
there
is that a nuclear shelter well that's a
i think that's a missile silo
do you know what these shelters look
like like this this look this is a
moscow uh uh
nuclear shelter right here is this kind
of what it looks like i it's hard for me
to see it
over there i don't have my just be
curious i'd be curious to know what
these nuclear shelters look like
that's the one i was looking at right
there i think that's a um
russia ready for doomsday it's deeply
buried
that's a i i think that's a missile silo
i mean that looks like the head works
for a missile silo but that could be
that could be the headworks to one of
their wha one of their shelters but that
that looks like the uh uh a missile silo
to me so fema would say we have nuclear
shelters uh they probably would because
they're you know uh they're optimists
and they uh they always put the best
possible possible spin on thing but we
but we don't uh even for our political
military leadership uh
the most famous
uh
shelter in the americas cheyenne
mountain norad the nora
alternate headquarters okay uh this was
built in the
designed in the 40 late 40s and early
50s and it was designed to survive an
atomic attack where's that uh it's in
cheyenne mountain uh is that wyoming
where is it yeah uh
uh
near peterson air force base don't no no
the the state as well as i do uh i think
it's in colorado
but i'm not solely sure that there's
still a state but it's very close to
peterson air force base which is norad
headquarters and space command
headquarters and and cheyenne mountain
is located near there it used to be it's
now the alternate uh headquarters and uh
yeah uh and uh it's inside of a mountain
and the buildings are are on springs to
survive a shock wave and that's the best
hardest facility we have that facility
will not survive an attack from a
hydrogen bomb uh it'll survive an atomic
bomb but it's not hard enough for an
atomic bomb a hydrogen bomb their
shelters will survive attacks
probably even by our most powerful
weapon which is the was the b83 and uh
some of these shelters are
we call them shelters but yamantal
mountain for example and we we we still
don't know the purpose maybe it's for
these
oligarchs who are fleeing to the ural
mountains but uh the yamanta mountain
facility is is is like an underground
city that can survive a uh a a nuclear
attack is this is this a nuclear shelter
this is an article guardian did saying
how the u.s has prepared for nuclear
armageddon in this picture they're
talking about this was
something they started working on since
the truman days oh i just prefer i don't
know that looks like uh
i know that some millionaires have
purchased old atlas silos and uh that
looks like one of those uh you know uh
you know and this atlas was hardened to
survive an attack and uh uh
but
uh yeah that probably is a uh somebody's
personal fallout shelter from a
converted atlas how do we play defense
against this like
say the millionaires or whoever but okay
so nuclear war happens
i mean these shelters are not going to
fit 330 million people so it's not like
there are these shelters uh
how are you gonna manage shelters if
something were to happen and even an
individual family okay with food
shortages
or any of that stuff you know you got
people that own a lot of weapons
themselves a lot of you know ammo a lot
of guns just in case something were to
happen how does the average family as
well as the u.s government
proactively play defense in case
something were to happen
okay
uh
let me uh
one of the things we should have done
uh was listen to ronald reagan and
and deployed the strategic defense
initiative
uh which was uh you know uh that and
that's one of the things we still could
do as a government uh you know the
strategic defense initiative was
designed to render nuclear missiles
obsolete by estab deploying high-tech
space-based defenses that could shoot
them down before they could reach us you
know the best solution or the the best
defense against the nuclear war is to
not get hit in the first place by
shooting down the missiles before they
reach our territory
and that's what reagan had planned to do
and you know history goes through
cycles where technology will sometimes
favor the defense
and those tend to be more stable safer
times because if you're the defender you
have to worry less about getting
attacked because the technology favors a
defensive posture okay
other times in military history uh uh
the technology favors the aggressor it
offends favors offensive operations that
was like world war ii
uh you know when uh the introduction of
tanks in combination with air power and
mobile infantry
gave
the advantage to aggressors and to
people who conducted offensive
operations
and those are more dangerous less stable
times because he who strikes first tends
to win we are living in the most
dangerous and least stable times because
the invention of nuclear weapons mated
with missile technology enables you to
destroy another country's
retaliatory capabilities
in 30 minutes or less
uh
and then and now it's getting worse and
worse uh the technologies are getting
better and better uh at being able to
destroy retaliatory capabilities with
cyber attack with emp attack you can do
it at the speed of light and so the
truism that he who strikes first wins is
becoming more and more true you know to
the point that the temptation to do
nuclear pearl harbor on us may become
irresistible and we do not do nuclear
pearl harbors our our nuclear strategy
is not based on striking first it's
based on striking second and deterrence
and being there and that and that puts
us in an increasingly vulnerable and
dangerous position
but we could reverse this potentially
and this was the vision that reagan had
wasn't just his idea there was a
brilliant scientist robert jostro who
wrote a book called
how to make nuclear weapons obsolete and
it was the inspiration for this to
deploy space-based missile shield you
know that would be able to intercept
these missiles edward teller the great
the guy who invented the hydrogen bomb
was all for this he was working on uh
there were a number of of technologies
that were very promising that sdi had
and we should bring back the strategic
defense initiative one of these
technologies was called brilliant
pebbles
and it was ready to be deployed
by under the clinton administration but
the clinton administration for
ideological reasons uh you know believed
in mutual assured destruction uh you
know thought the abm treaty was the
cornerstone of strategic stability and
the left has always hated ballistic
missile defense it's funny uh you know
they they hate nuclear weapons but they
hate ballistic missile defense too and
so they're against both us having
nuclear weapons or us having ballistics
do they publicly hate it but privately
love it or is it just they hate it
period they hate it period okay for
ideological reasons especially if it's
in the possession of the united states
they hate it they don't seem to have be
that much bothered by russian or chinese
nuclear weapons or their defenses they
don't complain about that but whenever
we try to improve our nuclear
weapons or improve our defenses the left
screams bloody murder over it
and then and it's happening in the biden
administration now i mean i just
explained how some of our most important
nuclear systems have been canceled by
president biden you know that we really
need even though we're under this great
threat from russia what a time to be
canceling our nuclear strength um uh but
uh
we could deploy brilliant pebbles
probably in five years for 20 billion
and it would completely change it has
the potential of completely reversing
this situation so that we would then
have the advantage as the defender and
uh and
the the best scenario would be to start
a defensive strategic arms race with our
adversaries because i wouldn't care if
if they were deploying brilliant pebbles
and strategic defense initiatives of
their own because if you're in a
defensive arms race that makes the
situation more and more stable and both
all sides start to feel more and more
secure because they're better and better
defended against a against the first
strike so there is a technological way
out and that's one way out but
if i could speak to a larger issue uh
you know because i uh you know i don't
want to come across here as if
technology is
is al is the only card we have to play
we have a bigger uh
potentially a more important card to
play
uh you know and the way we should be
thinking about
waging the new cold war
is the way we won the old cold war
we have
for all their military power and nuclear
power and specialized weapons like emp
and all the rest
uh we have an enormous advantage
i hope we can hold on to it in the free
world and that is
you know i i believe our systems uh
believe in have a truer understanding of
human nature and of how to organize the
good society
our belief and freedom okay is one of as
a
is is a is a great advantage that we
have over them our systems are
the vision and unfortunately we're
moving away from that so
maintaining
free elections in this country discourse
rationalism being the way we were for
example under the reagan administration
all right uh you know when you could
have conversations and and and
rationally solve problems we need to get
back to being that way the further away
we move toward authoritarians type type
we become as vulnerable as they are to
this
and this gives us staying power the fact
that our understanding that our society
is truer to human nature is gives us
greater staying power so our objective
should be
to
you know to split this
the russian chinese alliance in the new
cold war to try to contain china
uh to avoid getting in a nuclear any
kind of a war to get it and avoid any
kind of a major war with with these
powers as long as we can to avoid that
because that's a game that they are more
likely to win than we are you know uh
they're better prepared for it they
they're that's what their whole
societies are geared toward they they
exist for warfare okay
uh
and uh the soviet union
you know was the most formidable
military tyranny that ever existed in
history okay but it was based on lies
and these other systems are based on
lies they're based on a fundamental
misunderstanding of human nature of what
makes the good society and these
internal contradictions if you can
avoid fighting them long enough they
will they will destroy themselves and
self-destruct if you can just avoid
getting in a conflict with them long
enough and contain them for long enough
that was the strategy that worked in the
cold war it was based on an article
called the x article that was written
anonymously by a guy who later was
discovered to be george kennan a state
department brilliant man who said
this is how we need to deal with the
soviet union in the long run you know
they will fall of their own internal
contradictions uh they are so paranoid
they're going to spend themselves to
death
with their defense budgets so just try
to keep the peace and and
and contain these guys long enough and
they'll just self-destruct and will win
and that's how we won the cold war and
without it becoming a world war which is
a miracle in history because normally
when you have superpowers confronting
each other you know whether it's uh the
persian empire and alexander's macedonia
or the carthaginians and the romans uh
you know uh these things usually end
badly they usually end with a huge uh a
world war in effect to resolve the uh
the dispute but here's here's what i'd
like to do here's what i like to do
i think i can listen to you for four
hours
and i'm getting smarter and i think
people feel the same way as well and i
don't think two hours was enough
and and folks if you feel i'm looking at
the commentary if you feel the same way
as i feel give it a thumbs up subscribe
and order his book we're gonna put the
link below to his latest book blackout
warfare attacking the us electric power
grid a revolution in military affairs
title let's put that in the comment
section in the chat box
would you would you be open to a round
two i don't think this was uh long
enough i think we need to do around two
if you're okay with that i i would love
to do another one
uh because some of the stuff you're
going into i think you know how i also
almost process the information you're
sharing
we've got a lot of different types of
guests you know
billionaires mobsters cia fbi military
athletes comedians ufc fighters you name
them we've had
a lot of different types of guests that
we've had that we've interviewed um
and and some of the information is kind
of like oh it's very motivational oh
that's very entertaining that was
insightful oh i never knew that's kind
of how that's kind of cool man i was
great i feel motivated i feel like i
feel like i can go out my dreams become
a reality
but i think
this is very very super necessary in
formation for every parent
every citizen every person that has big
plans in their lives with their wives
with their kids for their husbands for
their families i think they need to be
educated on the information you're
sharing and you're bringing it from an
angle of extreme reason and rational
uh and an element of being suspicious
and paranoid which i think is very
healthy so if you're open to it i'd love
to do a round two with you and i'm not
talking a long time from now i'd like to
do round two with you sooner rather than
later if you're okay with that oh
certainly i'm i'm you know pleased that
you're willing to uh put up with me you
know i can listen to you for hours and
i'm not kidding with you uh yeah i would
but sure i'd be glad to come back i you
know i think this is really important
and uh uh
you know i i thank you for the
opportunity to share my point of view
which is a distinct minority at this
time i mean all almost all the voices on
both sides of the political aisle are
calling for let's get more deeply
involved in that war with ukraine let's
focus on defeating russia and ukraine
and i think that that is a
self-destructive strategy and people
have lost sight of the big picture in
terms of how we should be
protecting america's national interests
at this at this crucial hour
well we're gonna follow up with you for
the next one uh
dr peter pry folks if you just got in go
to the beginning watch the whole thing
stay tuned based on the reaction i'm
getting from you guys expect us to do
part two here very soon share this with
your loved ones family friends i think
everybody needs to hear this perspective
that we're not getting from mainstream
media i think we're back at it again
thursday do we have podcasters
oh thursday is a big roundtable
libertarian debate with spike cohen with
dave smith which him and joe jorgensen
had an issue she didn't have good words
to say about her uh
jessica vaughan and we're having larry
sharp who's running for libertarian
governor in new york i can't wait to
talk to you to these guys the last one
wasn't uh too pretty it was tough this
next one here they're coming to prove me
wrong that that's the right comment
so we'll see you guys on thursday yes
we'll see you guys on thursday take care
bye bye bye bye
you